Speaker 1: Trump has been caught lying.
He was not being audited by the IRS in the
way that he claimed to be.
This so far, we haven't yet gotten the tax
returns themselves, but we will.
Based on the House Ways and Means Committee
vote yesterday.
We're going to get the tax returns within
a few days, maybe by the end of this week,
maybe over the weekend, maybe by the start
of next week.
And we will deal with that.
But one of the big takeaways is that the IRS
mandatory audits for Trump when he became
president were essentially nonexistent.
Trump lied, Sarah Huckabee Sanders lied, and
so many of them lied.
Let's go back to we looked at some of this
clip earlier.
Congressman Lloyd Doggett explained Trump
was not being audited.
I hope I'm roughly at the right moment here.
Let's see exactly where we are.
Here we go.
Speaker 2: 2015 to 2020, just to be clear.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's correct.
And I think what I find surprising.
Yes.
Focus had been on the IRS audit and whether
it was being done properly.
Is the IRS did no audits at all until such
time as the day they received Mr. Neal's request
for these documents.
And that day they requested the first audit.
They have yet to complete a single audit of
Mr. Trump.
And I think they'll also be surprised by what's
not there with the tax returns, and that is
supporting data.
Any taxpayer who goes in for audit has to
produce some receipts and some affidavits
and some substantiation.
And that just seems to be missing from what
we've been providing.
Speaker 1: That is absolutely fascinating.
So even what they have obtained, it seems
as though they really haven't gotten the full
data.
Here is Congressman Richard Neal, who chairs
the House Ways and Means Committee.
Expanding on this, we.
Speaker 3: Argued for an examination of how
the audit process played out.
Once staff went to visit the IRS at once,
staff had a chance to go to some of the other
locations that are within the jurisdiction
of the IRS.
They quickly concluded that, in fact, the
audit did not occur.
There were no audits in a timely manner.
And that goes, I think, for 2017, 2018 and
2019.
And I'm restrained by the speech and debate
clause from talking about the other issue
that that we had on our agenda.
So the mandatory initiative, it's highlights
the idea that it's sort of a two tiered system.
If you are at the top, you really have no
chance of getting audited.
And as Steve Horsford pointed out today in
our our get together of the Democratic caucus
on the committee, your chances of being audited
if you claim the earned income tax credit
are far better than being audited for people
who are at the very top of the economic system.
Speaker 1: Now, that's an entire other story
we should talk about.
But this claim that the IRS is targeting rich
conservatives certainly does not appear to
be true.
And that's a bigger story.
As a reminder, here is Donald Trump claiming
that everything is under audit and it's all
so complicated nobody would understand it
anyway.
This was at the end of 2018 already.
Speaker 3: He gave me a fair interview the
other day, so I might as well ask him a question.
All right.
Thank you, Mr. President.
And picking up there, you told me the other
day that you are an open book.
So I think I am an open book.
So point blank, Democrats go after your tax
returns.
Will you try to block that or will you allow
them?
Now, I look, as I've told you, they are underwater.
They have been for a long time.
They're extremely complex.
People wouldn't understand and they're done
by among the biggest and best law firms in
the country.
Same thing with the accounting firms.
The accountants are.
A very large, powerful firm from the standpoint
of respect.
Speaker 1: Extremely powerful.
From the standpoint of respect.
Don't forget that the respected.
Speaker 3: Big, firm.
Speaker 1: Big and wide firm.
Gerth.
Speaker 3: A great law firm where you would
you know it very well.
They do these things.
They put them in.
But people don't understand tax returns.
You know, you do a filing of over 100 pages,
I believe, which is in the offices.
And when people went and saw that filing and
they saw the magnitude of it, they were very
disappointed.
Speaker 1: And they cried and they said, Sir,
there's so many pages and such font.
Speaker 3: Well, the you know, the detail,
you'd get far more from that.
And I guess we filed that down three times,
but you get far more from that than you could
ever get from a tax return.
But when you're under audit and I'm on a very
continuous audit because there are so many
companies and it is.
Speaker 1: It's like a moebius strip of audits,
quite frankly.
Speaker 3: Big company, far bigger than you
would even understand.
Speaker 1: It's a bigger company than you've
got, Jim.
Speaker 3: It's a it's a great company, but
it's big and it's complex and it's probably
feet high.
It's a very complex instrument.
And I think that people wouldn't understand
it.
Speaker 1: But I don't know if a tax return
is an instrument.
But okay.
So there was Trump talking about even if it's
all under audit, continuous audit, and it's
too complicated for you to even understand.
And then here was then press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders also making similar claims.
Speaker 2: I want you to help me clarify something
that we podium here on taxes.
You said I think Matt met on Tuesday that
as long as his taxes are under audit, he's
not going to release them.
His 2016 taxes, to our knowledge, are not
under audit unless they are my understanding,
and I will double check.
But the president's taxes, no matter who the
president is, actually immediately go under
audit.
All are being filed.
So that's actually.
Speaker 1: Wasn't happening though were.
Speaker 2: Inaccurate back to us.
But I'll double check to be one.
So my question really is I want I said, well.
Speaker 1: So lies after lies after lies.
So I think the strategy here first we need
to see what we learn from the tax returns
and that may modify the strategy.
But absent the content, remember, he said
he would release his tax returns when Obama
releases his birth certificate or whatever
the birth certificate we had, the tax returns
he blocked, he was going to release his taxes
if he won the presidency.
He won the presidency in 2016, didn't release
the tax returns.
Once the audits were finished, he was going
to release them.
Turns out there weren't actually audits going
on.
So it's lie upon lie upon lie.
We're going to get them we're going to get
them some soon and we're going to learn all
about it.
Folks, Friday, we are two days away from an
incredible David Pakman show event.
We are doing an end of the year membership
special where your first month's payment and
this applies to gifted memberships as well
will be donated to an organization that sends
cash to people who need it.
One of the most efficient ways of helping
people is actually sending them cash so they
can decide for themselves what they most need.
Your first month's payment on Friday, if you
use the coupon code we're going to be creating,
will be donated and doubled.
We're going to be doubling the first $15,000.
All you need to do to be ready for Friday
is go to David Pakman dot com top right of
the page.
It'll there's like a box where you put in
your email address to get on our newsletter,
get on our newsletter Friday morning you will
get instructions for how to sign up at a discount.
We donate that first payment and it gets doubled
the first $15,000.
Incredible stuff.
We'll take a quick break and be
right back.